major question that we've had if the
donald trump administration repeals
Obamacare what would it get replaced
with and what would happen to people's
health insurance well most Republicans
who want to repeal have really no plan
for a replacement Donald Trump talked
about repeal and replace at his address
on Tuesday but he didn't actually
propose a plan to replace the affordable
care act however there is actually a
Republican congressional leadership
proposal about the plan it's very
similar to what Paul Ryan proposed last
year and it has leaked and much of it is
not at all surprising the health
research firm a Valier health and the
consulting firm McKinsey and company
analyzed the plan big surprise
the report implies that millions of
people would end up without in health
insurance coverage if this leaked plan
were to be made the replacement to the
Affordable Care Act the core action of
the Republican plan that leaked would
get rid of income based tax credits
which help poor people and replace them
with these nonsense age-based tax
credits which give people the same
amount regardless of income if the main
issue is some people based on their
income can't afford health insurance
then you should target the credits
towards people based on income and the
effect of this and you're in your sort
of average hypothetical state that has
done the Medicaid expansion under
Obamacare and has about three hundred
thousand people in the individual market
enrollment as a result of this leaked
Republican replacement to the Affordable
Care Act enrollment would drop 30% and
90,000 people would lose coverage this
roughly equates to millions of people
losing coverage throughout the country
as a whole from the report we have a
couple of graphics from the report as
you can see if you look at the image on
the right individual market enrollment
would drop very very significantly
another hundred and fifteen thousand
people in addition to these numbers
would probably lose coverage because
they're on Medicaid and wouldn't be able
to find an affordable private plan if
the Medicaid expansion was undone and
losses of coverage could be even worse
in states that didn't expand Medicaid by
the way most of those states are
republican-controlled
in states like that and we have another
graphic to show you in the states that
did not do the Medicaid expansion this
leak the Republican plan could lead to a
50% drop in coverage if you look again
at the Box on the right it suggests
130,000 existing enrollees would no
longer be able to afford a plan in
non-expansion States this is a huge
problem but in addition you also need to
add to this that if you repeal Obamacare
70 million Americans that rely on
Medicaid half of them children many
disabled people may not have coverage
doesn't really sound pro-life to me does
it not at all and the Republicans will
have to come up with something the ball
is in their court now and if they don't
or if they come up with something bad
many of their constituents are going to
stand to lose their coverage because
some of them are on the Medicaid
expansion it was very easy for them to
try to come up with a way to repeal and
replace Obamacare when Obama was an
often yeah of course that legislation
was never going to get passed now that
it actually will they got to come up
with something good when you've got a
Republican president House Senate and by
and large a lot of Republican governors
what Democrat can you find to blame if
you lose your coverage in the stat in
the situation we have now last thought
on this the Republicans talking about
marketplace solutions if you believe
that there should be some areas of life
that are not market solutions but that
the government handles like for example
roads or education military etc once you
concede that there are some aspects of
society that the government should
handle rather than the marketplace if
you want health insurance to be a market
situation you need to justify why that
makes sense and the data don't justify
it and we need to continue to demand
that Republicans explain if you're ok
with anything not being a marketplace
solution even roads or education or the
military prove that health insurance
should be a market solution I've not
heard one convincing argument since and
this is something that's being discussed
on our reddit discussion forum I
encourage you to join us there david
pakman.com slash re d di t Gamefly is
sort of like netflix for video games
they have
over 8,000 new and classic games for
xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low use price there's never any due
dates or late fees and our audience can
get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you would return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s